foreign
President Biden announced that he's
going to forgive ten thousand dollars
worth of student loans for anyone making
less than 125 thousand dollars court
cases have ensued uh questioning whether
he has the constitutional right to
actually do that
um
and of course he did this before the
midterms uh when which was a politically
genius move by the way uh to try to get
that get everybody's eye off the ball of
the failing economy and so forth because
the looks most most experts say
regardless of your uh your political
leaning that the dims are going to take
a bloodbath at the midterms and so he's
doing anything he can to get the eye off
of that
and then this comes out and this not
from right leaning
media Source from a left-leaning media
Source called NPR very interesting yeah
they're saying that now up to 800 000
borrowers who thought they were going to
be part of the relief may not be part of
the relief now those are borrowers who
had Perkins loans and ffel loans that
were issued and managed by private Banks
but not guaranteed by the federal but
guaranteed they're guaranteed by the
federal government but yes but
guaranteed sorry yeah but once the
Mainstay of the federal loan programs
until the ffe ffel program ended in 2010
so if you've got an old student loan
prior to 2010 in a remarkable reversal
that will affect the fortunes of many
student loan borrowers the U.S
Department of Education is quietly
changed its guidance
around who qualifies for President
Biden's sweeping student loan student
debt relief plan this from NPR today
according to Federal data more than 4
million borrowers still have
commercially held ffel loans until
Thursday the Department's own website
advise these borrowers that they could
consolidate these loans into Federal
Direct Loans and thereby qualify for
Relief under Biden's debt cancellation
program but on Thursday the department
quietly
changed that language so as not to raise
a Ruckus in the media uh uh we read it
we read it we read it so the quiet part
goes away now
because there's 22 million of you out
there so we just made the quiet part go
away you just found out that they did
this
I told you
when this happened that it was not going
to work exactly the way they said it was
going to work and besides that they
haven't even said how it's going to work
completely I told you that the
Department of Education had no notice
ahead of time student loan dot gov had
no notice ahead of time that there was
going to be a student loan forgiveness
announced out of the White House if
you're going to announce a sweeping
program that the federal government is
going to have to Institute prior to
announcing it you normally if you're the
president would let the Departments know
that they're going to have to Institute
it they had no knowledge of it hint
everyone knew it wasn't really going to
happen
and here are the beginnings of the
unravelings an Administration official
tells NPR that roughly 800 000 borrowers
would now quietly
be excluded from relief I added it
quietly because quietly's all in this NP
article NPR article although it's not
quiet anymore see you put it out right
well I think that's the key is that we
kind of need to put that in the
megaphone because these are people who
are already breathing signs of relief
that they're already counting on this
forgiveness because Biden sounded
confident it was going to happen
it's a little nervous so sad it's very
sad you know you know what screws up
your hope you want to steal your hope
when you place your hope in the wrong
things
let me tell you where to place your hope
okay there's two places that you can
count on the rest of them are Gonna Let
You Down
if you're looking at a picture of your
spouse sorry it's Gonna Let You Down
if you're looking at a picture of your
Mom and Dad sorry I'm Gonna Let You Down
if you're looking at a picture of your
boss
sorry it's Gonna Let You Down
if you're looking at a picture of Jesus
that one's going to work you can place
your hope there and if you look in the
mirror
you can place your hope there if you
look and you see a picture of President
Biden or president Trump either one you
place your hope there it's going to let
you down God's point in my picture in
the lobby Gonna Let You down because I'm
not responsible for fixing your life
you're responsible for fixing your life
and Biden is not responsible for fixing
your life and Trump is not responsible
for fixing your life it is your job to
fix your life our job is to tell you you
can do it Go kid go get him skid him go
for it
but I'm not giving you any money you're
going to make the money to get out of
that I'm not gonna wave any magic wands
from over here I don't have one my
batteries are low on the one I do have
it doesn't work no Harry Potter action
here
we don't have that at Ramsey you're just
all we are is your biggest cheerleaders
and your teachers and your guide we will
show you how we believe you can do it we
can prove to you that you can do it if
you'll get off your assumptions and go
do it
well yes 100 yes there there have been a
lot of emotions around this you know
from the very beginning
lots of discussions a lot of promotions
around here we bottle them but that
being said I've talked to a lot of
people who of course there's people who
are upset and don't think it's going to
happen but there's a lot of people who
are genuinely counting on this counting
on this that's what I'm telling you
you're gonna have your hope get screwed
when you place your Hope on the wrong
things well how do you think people
should see this moving forward people
who are still qualified for this do you
think they should be nervous that
potentially they could quietly fall out
of it or what's kind of your thought on
how people could should look at this
uh my thought from day one has been
don't wait on them to fix your life
because by the time they get if they
actually do Institute this it may
require an act of Congress
many legal Scholars are saying that you
can't really spend 300 billion dollars
that's 300 000 million without
congress's approval you can't just do
that as a stroke of a pen as a president
you don't really have the constitutional
right to do that or at least that's what
some people are saying I don't know much
about it but it sounds reasonable to me
so it requires an act of Congress and
you know what when we were kids we used
to say well that's going to take longer
than an act of Congress you know why we
say that because an act of Congress
takes freaking forever Congress is
slower than Christmas or gridlocked they
don't do half of what they say they're
going to do three quarters 90 98.2
percent of what they say they're going
to do and so you know if it requires an
act of Congress you're screwed if if
Biden can really do it with a stroke of
a pen it's ten thousand dollars you have
ninety eight thousand dollars in student
loan debt quit acting like your life's
better go get yourself out of debt
ten thousand dollars ain't gonna fix
your life by the way it's gonna help
and I'm not mad at you if you take it
but it it's I
yeah there's so many indications here
that this is so much about the midterms
and so much about Optics and posturing
and so much about politics more so than
actual financial planning so it's going
to be an interesting few months I think
yeah 30 days from now yeah you know
we're 30 days off from the middle they
said that the the application should be
out anytime now so oh yeah very telling
that would be interesting we'll see if
it comes out before the midterms if you
actually have an application in your
hands a place to sign up on a website
that they've actually programmed so how
are you going to prove 125 000 income
limit in a year that's not closed
oh there's that
jeez the why is it so hard to punch
holes in it's just like swiss cheese
this is the Ramsay show